westminster in full spin mode all
morning leadership candidates canvassed
and cajoled
until the time came
for another important moment along this
corridor we're gonna announce the
results of the second ballot in the
leadership election suella bravoman is
eliminated from the
contest and the others are able to go
forward
to a further ballot on monday
one of those going through was foreign
secretary liz truss who earlier in the
day held her official campaign launch
and appeared to inject momentum into a
stalling start we are at a critical
moment for our country
we face huge challenges now is the time
to be bold we cannot have business as
usual we don't have a moment to lose and
i will work with colleagues from right
across the party to lead a strong and
united team but the team she's been on
since 2019 is boris johnson's the two
candidates ahead of you
in this race have one thing in common
they're a break from boris johnson
rishi sonak resigned from his government
you did not and penny mordant was never
in his cabinet or only for a brief
moment is boris johnson's tacit backing
of you the kiss of death for your
candidacy given that the party wants
change even if you did not the change we
need to deliver
is change on the economy
we've had sluggish growth for two
decades and we need a new economic plan
but questions too about why she stayed
in government when others quit
i'm a loyal person
i'm loyal to boris johnson i supported
our prime minister's aspirations
but her backers insist whichever
direction she heads in they're behind
her are you worried that this trust is
stalling in this campaign no not at all
absolutely not no i thought that was
fantastic and you know
the liz
liz embodies
the loyalty and the integrity and they
are excellent qualities for a candidate
to have i think that will carry her a
long way
do you think that rishi sanakan penny
mordent who is now the biggest challenge
for liz isn't she that she uh could
steal the march on her well the thing is
beth i'm not kind of that interested in
in the other candidates i think as liz
rightly said on the panel we've got a
really good diverse range of talented
people who've put themselves forward has
morden's momentum surprise for mr sunak
and this man still going forward and in
the lead
sonic's team are now more confident that
their man can make it to the magic
number that's 120 mp backers to secure
his place in the final two but this race
is unpredictable and nothing is settled
penny mordant is picking up momentum as
liz truss battles for more votes and as
the candidates slog it out into the
weekend in interviews and tv debates it
can all change still even the most
seasoned political operators around here
are unsure about how the cards will fall
this one whose candidate swella
braverman is now out knows what she does
next will be important to this race i'm
now waiting to see what suella decides
i've promised suellar i will vote the
same way as suella most of the team have
agreed that they will wait to see what
suella decides so there's a block of 27
votes for suella you're saying that all
27 could potentially go to one other
candidate i'm not in a position to say
that i'm afraid
mps all have their own minds
five contenders left after a frenzied
week and as mps leave westminster for
the weekend there'll be no let up in the
campaigning or canvassing in the battle
to become the next pm beth rigby sky
news westminster